this episode is brought to you by
Shopify set up your business with a 90
day free trial from Shopify by following
the link below humans are a very
successful species in the past hundred
years alone our population has grown
from around 2 billion to over seven and
a half billion just 20 years ago our
population was only six billion our
species has expanded tremendously over
the course of our time on earth and we
now inhabit many vastly different
environments around the globe
there's very little that the human race
can't overcome and that's led some to
ask the question are we too successful
will there come a point at which we
simply have too many mouths to feed and
not enough food to go around
in this episode we'll examine the
current state of food production around
the world and determine roughly how many
humans our agriculture is capable of
supporting let's get one thing out of
the way up front we're nowhere near the
earth becoming overpopulated the only
people who make this claim are acting in
bad faith usually to push reprehensible
agendas like eugenics depending on the
population models you use the planets
carrying capacity could be up to 40
billion people it's just a matter of how
those people consume now let's take a
look at the current state of agriculture
and hunger around the world as of 2018
about 800 million people around the
world experienced a lack of sufficiently
nutritious food earning them the
designation hungry most of these people
live in regions with underdeveloped
agricultural systems like sub-saharan
Africa but a lack of agricultural
infrastructure is only part of the
problem regions that are embroiled in
conflict or that have high levels of
poverty also suffer from widespread
hunger war leads to poverty poverty to
hunger and hunger reinforces poverty
it's a deadly cycle that is very
difficult to break but even while nearly
a billion people lack reliable access to
nutritious food global food production
is humming along nicely it's estimated
that the world's farmers produce enough
food to feed one-and-a-half times the
total world population that's over 10
billion people a population we're not
expected to reach for another 30 years
at least if we produce that much food
why do so many people suffer hunger and
starvation this is a multi-faceted
problem waste in efficient distribution
and climate change all play major roles
in preventing the efficient disbursement
of food to the world's at-risk
populations let's start with the problem
of waste
it's estimated that globally 30 to 40
percent of all food is waste
that is a massive amount of food the
reasons for this waste vary by country
India for example loses 30 to 40 percent
of their fresh produce because they lack
cold storage infrastructure in many
regions in other countries like the u.s.
famous for its massive portions much of
the waste comes from people simply
throwing away large amounts of food
because they have too much on their
plates and large grocery chains just
dump excess food because it's cheaper
than transporting it to places that
could put it to good use this is where
distribution comes in why repackage and
distribute unused food if there's not a
financial incentive to do so
in recent months we've seen American
farmers leave mountains of potatoes to
rot and dump hundreds of gallons of milk
down the drain because the market dried
up then there's the looming threat of
climate change we're already beginning
to see the adverse effect of a rapidly
changing global climate most notably
with more violent weather the spread of
disease and the destruction of crops
it's estimated that by 2050 the United
States Midwest will see at least a 20%
decline in corn yields as will Indonesia
and Brazil will see a 16% reduction some
colder regions will become too warm to
support cold weather crops warmer areas
will become too hot and coastal regions
will experience too much rain of course
there will be some parts of the world
that actually become more hospitable to
some crops but these will not be enough
to offset the loss of production in
other regions now we see the real heart
of the problem we already produce enough
food to feed the entire world population
but if we don't safeguard and update our
existing methods of food production and
the population continues to grow as
projected the same old problems of waste
distribution and climate change will
make it even more difficult to keep
everyone fed so what kind of solutions
do we have for starters we could
transition to a less environmentally
damaging source of protein meat animals
especially cows are a major contributor
to climate change add to this the fact
that they require large amounts of land
and food themselves not to mention the
inhumane nature of the animal
agriculture industry and you've got a
strong argument to transition to more
efficient and humane sources of protein
or at least replace red meat with
poultry which is much less
environmentally damaging another
promising advancement in farming is the
development of indoor vertical farms
these highly productive farms grow all
sorts of nutritious foods in a climate
controlled environment where they're
protected from the elements and can be
installed right in densely populated
hubs like major cities making
distribution a much simpler process
vertical farms also take up much less
space than traditional outdoor farms
because they're contained within
buildings and plant upwards instead of
outwards regarding waste and
distribution well that depends on the
country places that lack refrigeration
could obviously make an investment in
that area but in wealthy countries like
the u.s. it's a bit more difficult the
u.s. produces a huge amount of food and
much of it is wasted simply because of
our extravagant lifestyle we have a
major obesity problem in America but we
also have over 37 million people going
hungry coincidentally that's the same
number as the amount of Americans living
in poverty as we saw earlier poverty and
hunger is a self-reinforcing cycle one
easy step we could take is mandating
that all large grocery chains donate
their unsold food to homeless shelters
soup kitchens and other charitable
groups there is no reason for tens of
thousands of tons of food to end up in
dumpsters behind the store one final
method to help reduce local hunger and
improve community resiliency is to
develop mutual aid programs mutual aid
in a nutshell means looking out for
those in your community
every person being willing to help every
other person when they need it take the
seattle nonprofit city fruit for example
the city of seattle has tons of fruit
trees and much of the fruit those trees
produce ended up rotting on the ground
not doing anyone any good a group of
people saw a way to help fulfill a need
and started collecting fruit from around
the city and distributing it to
communities that lacked access to
nutritional food every year city fruit
collects and distributes tens of
thousands of pounds of nutritious local
fruit and helps keep their community
healthy and resilient this type of local
organizing can be done around the world
identifying useful local resources and
building systems of mutual aid to
strengthen communities this kind of
compassionate and egalitarian work
combined with investment in new climate
proof farming techniques could
drastically reduce the number of people
suffering from hunger the world over we
already produce all the food we need
it's just a matter of setting our
priorities straight and making sure we
invest in the means to distribute food
to the people that currently don't have
the access they need it'll take a lot of
compassion and hard work but we humans
are pretty inventive if you're one of
those people with big ideas that you
want to turn into your full time gig you
can turn that idea into a thriving
business with Shopify Shopify is your
one-stop shop for creating a sleek
modern online business with no coding
skills required you can build your brand
create a name and logo set up an online
store handle marketing and keep up with
your business finances there's a reason
Shopify is trusted by over a million
merchants around the world it's super
simple
hasil no headaches and a professional
business you can be proud of I'm living
proof I use Shopify to power my online
merch store and it's super easy turn
your big idea into an online business
and help support second thought while
you're at it
visit Shopify comm slash free - trial
slash second thought and start your 90
day free trial today